من عالم السياسه في مسائل عربيه واهم
ثلاثه مناصب سياسيه في بريطانيا بات
يشغلها رجال اصولهم من شبه القاره الهنديه
رئيس حكومه المملكه المتحده ريشيسوناك من
اصل هندي والان اصبح حمزه يوسف ضد اصل
الباكستاني رئيس حكومه
طبعا عمده لندن صادق خان وايضا رئيس
الوزراء الايرلندي ليوفراد كار وهو اول
زعيم حكومه ايرلندي من اصل هندي وبذلك هذه
المره الاولى التي يصبح فيها ابناء
المهاجرين رؤساء وزراء بريطانيا واسكتلندا
وايرلندا من اصول جنوب اسيويه لكن بالعوده
لحمزه يوسف هناك انعكاس اخر لهذا الفوز
يذكرنا ربما بالتاريخ والعلاقه المعقده
بين الهند وباكست حمزه من اصل الباكستاني
ويدعم بقوه انفصال اسكتلندا عن المملكه
المتحده التي يقودها سوناك ذو الاصل
الهندي